citizens of the reject Nation Catholic
boys react to the Russell crowe-led
spooky religious film the Pope's
Exorcist Greg are you excited I'm
excited I want to see why this is one of
Netflix's most viewed movies of 2012.
surprise sleeper hit yeah so uh hey
leave a like on the video uh if you are
Pious And subscribe to the channel if
you think that you will be admitted to
heaven when it's all said and done and
hey thanks to prepper for editing down
these highlights it's tough work and if
you guys want to see the unedited
version get everything that doesn't make
it to these reaction highlights come on
over to patreon.com the real rejects
join our congregation and be saved now
sync up with your own copy yeah you sync
up with your own copy that's right we
can't give you the whole movie because
that is a sin and we will go to heck
now let's watch the movie
[Music]
when we jeer at the Devil and tell
ourselves that he does not exist that is
when he is happiest oh oh I love father
Gabriel amorth hands out well
considering I'm a Satanist
sick 80s best decade ever
they're gonna sacrifice the pig they're
gonna kill the
pigs
oh my God the devil's tongue
is
a smart priest if it was me I would have
been like definitely the devil yep
there's no other possible explanation in
the 1980s questions stop now
voted to me
oh my God they are going to settle oh
they're gonna transfer to the pig yeah
let's go Drag Me to Hell
a boy possession how quaint
I've been watching so much English
television this programming is trash
you doubt me this is
he could have read Dante's Inferno
soon enough
said Jonathan Tucker I can possess
anyone I fools
the possibility of the journey
on anything it's refreshing to see
Russell Crowe in this let's add that
extra zest you have the power could you
Peg on Satan
what's gonna happen to this pig
[Applause]
poor piggy Satan's bacon you can sleep
now my son the demon is gone
wow he handles these exorcisms with such
ease yeah I would love to be exercised
by this guy I know comforted I feel like
I got this under control when he's
around
oh [__] is that Alex Esso
I know she was in this nope I'll take
this movie more serious now she's coming
in Netflix Queen all those Mike Flanagan
shows and now this scream Queens scream
Queen over here
[Music]
oh nothing better ain't nothing bad
gonna happen here today kids
pleasure to meet you welcome you and
your family to the diocese oh no no
please go for it give him a Bible Haley
Steinfeld and Finn wolfhard are gonna be
in a heap Ton of Trouble
this has actually been in my husband's
family for generations and we just
inherited it he passed actually it's so
cool to see Ralph Macchio playing a
priest I know
wires Amy get off of there before you
break your neck is that a cigarette put
that out right now please you just want
to get in trouble they're setting the
stage here chandelier is going to come
back
I guess in post-production they were
like just make everything look icky yeah
you got some like achy tint make this
look like it's rotting
the black phone
uh
rabbit from Donnie Darko
how is he so high up there before no
idea
or 14 minutes in and I'm feeling like a
lot of this is a rejected screenplay out
of The Conjuring Universe yeah this was
one of the scripts that could have been
the nun
see through to France were the Naked
Ladies dance
oh awesome Gold Mine Ark of the Covenant
we don't
we don't sit up and sell it we'll go
home if you could just at least watch
your brother maybe try and get him to
talk bring him up from the catacombs
please just keep an eye on your brother
we don't care a lot I do respect the
fact that they kept this R rated though
yeah it helps the boy was maladjusted a
temporary mental illness I use primitive
psychology the power of suggestion
so he just killed the animal yeah you
gotta really take this basic psychology
that far 98 of the cases that are
assigned to father and moth I then
further recommended by him to doctors
and psychiatrists ah the other two
percent
this is something that has confounded
all of Science and all of medicine for a
very long time that's my department I
call it
evil
copyright that word how did he manage to
pull off making the most badass priests
you are not a doctor but these practices
of yours could have damaging effects on
these people you're real overachiever
aren't you but I am a theologian I am a
lawyer I am a journalist and I am a
practical man I was also a pastor Mr War
so I know a fighting Squad when I see
one he's he's a really cool character
position of Chief exorcists be formally
vacated so what you're saying is that
evil does not exist the church is under
constant pressure to sharpen her
relevance numbers are down if evil does
not exist what then is the role of the
church we
Satan we have more questions for you
father amort there's been like 47 shots
in this one scene
I gotta make sure we get all this
does not stop cutting my position was
appointed by my Bishop my diocese is
wrong my
my Bishop is their Pope if you have a
problem with me oh so great they got him
you don't do my boss the pope is in fact
all the remorse you have not been
dismissed
he's going rogue I think we're also a
girl breaks so much to elevate this oh
yeah so much he was like what's a
project that I can just put all the way
on my back
so good do another one of my
Mediterranean places it's like we're
barely into the movie I'm like this
would just not be the same without him
whoa
jeez oh my god oh crisp them up wow this
movie is it's in no rush at all nope I
really wish it would pick up the pace
get bored
oh now you care about Henry
he's talking you're all going to die no
way it's exactly oh my God is he clawing
his face
this movie is just like an entertaining
rock and roll hits of all the cliches
yes there is nothing that we can do now
but he can recommend a good psychiatrist
I'm getting the heck out of here
I need to talk to someone at the
consulate who can help me I need a
specialist
a lot of those darker lighting does feel
inspired by the Flanagan movies I would
say specifically the lighting
maybe not as blue though but pretty blue
no that is
Jesus oh it says hate that's a Kate at
first which it said Rebel on his stomach
damaged
this priest yeah Ralph Macchio Daniel
Brule
way over your head whoa
Rob
OT
the Montage versus every priest this
movie is not at what I'm really enjoying
about it
it's the exact thing that shouldn't be
working for me which is how fast-paced
this [__] is it's freaking Django soji
Django
that is not Jamie Foxx Show
she's in white face okay it's okay
there's a case that needs your attention
and boy in Spain something about it
disturbs me greatly you know what I just
realized about this they treat his story
like it's a cop movie yes absolutely
yeah he's in a cop movie and they're in
a haunted house
I have a requested the Abby's records
will be brought to you in the library I
will continue investigating while you
are on your journey and I will call you
with the most Vital Information at the
midpoint orphanately
this demon sounds dangerous
not like the other demons hey I take
this kind of wicked fast-paced
entertainment over the pretentious
I thought this would play out remarkably
different yeah this movie is having so
much fun movie is shot like a serious
movie and it's edited like an action
comedy it is having a blast
hmm
the church sends someone an expert in
these matters
well I like the way his characters
Illustrated because he's going to factor
out everything before lasting being it's
disabled yeah yeah so the trauma thing
will actually factor into the story he's
upstairs
hello my friend
yeah I love the layers he brings these
like apathetic jovial qualities it just
feels like a real good it's very
multilarious very natural where I feel
like normally this kind of character
would be just so serious only about the
faith and nothing in life
damn I think that one might be one of
the better
like splits but Iris gags I've ever seen
what is your purpose I'm here for you
way to go man then you must know my name
I know your soul and every Shameless sin
that's not an answer you cannot oh get
ready my sins have been absorbed by the
one true Master are you afraid of him
Tails noise deep ubiquitous
you only do because God allows it
hello
this is just the beginning you don't
know not yet why who is that voice it
sounds so familiar my name is Knight
I am the devil and I'm here to do the
devil's work my nightmare is France
winning the World Cup
I can't hide behind your jokes forever
yes
oh
[Music]
hi Dick finally psychic
fightling oh smart preying on his trauma
whoa
wow is it the same Bird's little girl
was drawing maybe your son is under the
influence of a very powerful demon
removing the boy from this place could
be fatal that would be so horrifying
even if I'm not a Believer if you're
like oh baby seriously he was in the car
accident that killed his father he saw
his father impaled
wow that'll do number on You drama such
as you described can be a Gateway for
the devil suffering can make a soul
desperate for connection damn it but
we're all we all have drama we're all
possessed I have so much trauma why is
the devil never comfort me
what did I do got to get a little bit
more Trump because it's not right at the
cutoff Point Henry
now maybe maybe should have given the
daughter a heads up
you should have had this conversation
with the both of them maybe now
mommy's with the maggots now
[Music]
that is evil
oh
damn that's Swift what prayer do you
know that you would say over and over
even Under Pressure the Hail Mary but if
it is under pressure I would prefer to
say it in Spanish that's fine your job
is to pray I don't I don't think matter
to God what language it is do not
respond to anything he says or does your
job is to be impeccably you know any
jokes no you should learn some the devil
does not like jokes and I need you to
open for me work out a tight five how
did Captain Hook die Satan
what do you call a black guy flying an
airplane he looks a little scared Gabe
you run out for me last time like the
couch you are
and you made yourself with the release
you feel when I [__] you whoa damn
hardcore [__] I do like how it's an
actual we're entering the ring with him
yeah yeah I think let's go let's try to
exercise me isn't an Ascension of our
Lord Jesus Christ by The Descent of the
Holy Spirit he's fading the coming of
Our Lord for the judgments come on buddy
keep going
despite my own words
to keep going keep going
foreign
in order for him to beat this guy he's
gotta beat his own sins that's right
release the trauma why didn't you
believe me
wowie
cool visuals here yeah nice match
cutting it looks like a fun set
is that all you got and how about you
panties ever
oh that's a real Sin it's good before
your congregation like you're better
than them when you're [__] their
daughters oh my god wow man shut up
Thomas come on
this up later
yes we'll move you to a new dinosaur or
that than this yeah you took the Bates
your holy church will crumble from the
inside
wowie he's met his match that must have
been so fun for that boy eyes all I
could think throughout that scene is
what a fun day on Saturday I do have a
hard time just getting immersed into the
performance it's not it really is Fault
like the there's just something about or
I'm very much aware of watching a child
actor do this yeah but I wouldn't fault
the kid for that I want it's Eerie to
hear the adult voice but it's always
going to be like oh they looped it in
yeah it's a boy it feels like a
voiceover yeah kid matching it yeah
whereas like you take Reagan from
Exorcist like that sounds like it's
really coming from within her yeah and
he's manipulated the audio track I
promise it was made
she wanted me to
leave the priesthood I was a lover yes
that's different they're proverbial
Daughters of they changed of true
stories
how do we make this guy a hero for love
voice
Rosalia well who's having confession
and it uses it against us
as a distraction well you better grieve
fast
get some closure we need to find out the
name of this demon
knowing his name it weakens them an
investigative exorcism I have not
dispatch for you
no not it is nothing close enough to
Spanish
sure it's the root of so many languages
the Pope's vacation house you think they
it would have given been given a heads
up about this uh
upside down cross here we go
here we go you can now do that at
haunted attractions no problem
[Music]
oh yeah
try it yourself
hey someone needs to die
I hope it's him someone needs to be
pinned against a wall and thrown across
the room and levitated killed on the
ceiling
I just would not be sleeping alone
I would be like with Mom at the very
least at all times
yep
Mike Tyson is my name
[Laughter]
it's like a poltergeist movie with her
wants to be confined you know
creepy
whoa
damn she's been sinking into the bed
what
such a crazy true story
it's a lot more of a fun house movie
than I expected
I mean it definitely feels like it whoa
wants to be a Conjuring kind of movie
damn that's wild whoa this looks like it
would have been a really fun set
I mean they should go stay somewhere
else yeah they should absolutely go to a
hotel go back to America your dad left
us this place yes
we're not going anywhere for his memory
we stay here
it's one of her nails
whoa I'm so curious to know what this
director has done before yeah
everything is redacted oh we're at the
midpoint oh yeah where's that phone call
call him up I think we're at the exact
middle
you know your screenwriting structure
Mike
whoa
places like if Jack Nicholson played
yeah
and they are
the victims they're ones who would not
convert As Above So Below I feel like
whenever they light any kind of match
the big fire yeah someone's across the
set with a big old lamp to shine on
two Cross Keys a little guess
huh
brimstone
push with me whoa
damn
[Music]
Iron Maiden excellent hey this would be
really cool to discover yeah how creepy
that would be but cool
seal
secret note
he was the final hope
it looks like he's a prisoner the cage
for his own safety
they do this
when an exorcism fails
wow hey Google
Cardinal protector
it's locked
a friend here
must have a key it's the ring swallowed
it
he didn't poop it out when he died
you are gonna get like so many Airborne
pathogen-based diseases
and we swallowed all that
that's a huge ass key to swallow that's
how he died
how the F do you swallow that yeah
and its name is
the information just so shocking he's
having a heart attack yeah
one last bit of excitement useless
useless man over here
never gonna make that call
this movie really does lack atmosphere
though
it's got all the sets for it and the
lighting for it lacks mood and
atmosphere
significantly that is greatly elevated
by performances yeah like everyone's
really good we gotta get them closer to
hell
oh yeah let's go getting we'll send whoa
now there's a real Iron Maiden see if
I'm gonna hide all this I would build it
on like I build a really small house on
top of it it's not a cathedral like a
diocese Castle yeah
uh-oh
he's off the force he got us into this
time
whoa ew
that's why we need the Old Guard Vanquis
from this place one of the greatest
exorcists of all time
no no [__]
God everyone's just swallowing stuff
today
the eggs
The Exorcist and himself died his
channel I will summoned to the town of
Segovia it was this Mark in the year of
Our Lord 1475.
covia Accords 1475. damn he answered me
from the mouth of another
and then a third
possessions I'm getting it I'm getting
it
I hope young priest dies oh he's gonna
he's marked The Exorcist because
possessed himself everything that
happens after this
is the work of the devil wolf centuries
of persecution and torture all started
by the fry and done in the name of God
by the devil that is a great trick
so much information hey
it's okay mommy whoa Henry's okay
I just need your sister for a minute Amy
can you forgive me Mom
he's got that face down
but there's no eyebrow have an ass
this
is
an army and destroy the church oh my God
there's a bigger planet hand here the
whole franchise worth
[Music]
whoa oh my God you caused her to
somersault yeah
watch me
no hands
you can murder the girl in front of him
Exorcist Style
osmodius Lucifer
oh
jeez
you go that deep are you like injecting
into their windpipe like damn look at
this looks like the mummy yeah we have
his name I commit it to memory octopus
species
matter my mother
oh [__] oh [__] it didn't mean me
it wants you yet this demon feeds on
Exorcist it's the whole thing I thought
we knew that like an hour because glory
to why you're here
greater victory for the devil
and to claim the soul of the Pope's
Exorcist that title so we have what we
need to beat it
and to save the child that's Morris hey
we won
oh you guys got me I'm out of here so
long kid it's like Rumpelstiltskin 1942
so many of my friends would
and not me I committed the mortal sin of
not getting shot my life had been spared
it was my responsibility to give it
purpose and in my case it's the bird the
bird she was drawing and he vomited is
all connected but when it mattered I
failed
I did not help but I did not believe her
I should have she's hot now
the first thing at night
what does this never look like how big
is the dick
was I good I was an exorcist they
mentally Disturbed slowed my job but
that all changed because of her
oh she flipped ah upside down cross dive
Swan Dive of the sexual abuse they
covered up within the walls of the
Vatican City
that's their wings yeah
I absolve you of your sins the name of
the father
son
and of the Holy Spirit
amen so kick this Demon's ass yeah
I give you the Miraculous Medal
Holy Fire insurance
everything just feels like a set yeah
like it doesn't quite look real to me
and the wides are very kind of like
workmen-like
whoa did he barely sold to you Thomas
like your little bag of breath
now the voice sounds a lot more natural
and now he's all built up with his
Twisted face confessing to your God
wowie remember
hell because of you
it's visual you're only in my mind
why is he talking to that girl on the
ceiling get it off
oh dude you chose
you got a lot of resolve man come on man
what is your problem
s
damn his face is really mangled looks
like an orc he does like a little Goblin
oh he said his own name
damn they're doing English now whoa whoa
sweet sauce see when they do [__] like
that the demons
are they like dislocating his jaw are
they permanently damaging him or is this
something in like his perception of
everyone else yeah that's a great
question
Henry I love you go to him
good effect you must resist
you must resist
oh this kid is falling apart
stop breathing
it's like emaciated
holy [__]
laughs
[Music]
start eating some glass
how are they so good at climbing walls
they're always so good every demon was a
rock climber that all did Parkour in
some way yeah
do a flip
wowie all right get yourself to me yeah
wow
man they keep smashing mommy through
[__] a lot of a lot of big old stunts in
this movie
Cox director has an action movie
background yeah or something well the
action is the stuff that punches the
hardest and feels the most like engaged
you're all gonna die
ow someone come bless this bath water
they're in
because
say the words piggy oh oh wow he got out
of those easily
[Music]
you get makeup on the kid yeah
that's disgusting looks monsters
wow
oh dude how's it going to get out of
this one
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is cool
oh what have you done he took the demon
in yeah yeah when I see this place
Henry you came back to me you're safe
now uh for now
go hey hey Junior we have to go let's go
see just like containing it right now
yeah I guess he's just like fighting it
until they can get out your soul is mine
your soul is mine
Flawless victory
whoa
not so hot now Arya
no
no oh the Army's going to work you would
sacrifice yourself to save those
children and now you are mine
ah fight it eat a Bible drink a gallon
of holy water go
father
thank you Father for you have sinned and
that's the last we ever see of them yep
Vatican game
I enjoy the personality of this demon
he's got a big old game plan too it's
got big goals I would have just jumped
out the window if that was your goal
and it goes right back to not talking
ever again impale the mom yeah
I bring It full circle
no
world
say what mother Mary
[Music]
oh damn no they did it
oh that's mean
still torturing him with this one piece
of trauma
it was so goof yeah
he's gone your friend enjoy my great
pleasure to exclude his soul good vocab
fight it it is just in your head he's
not here the little piggy is slopping at
hell's trough where he belongs I love
that Russell Crowe committed to this I
know pray with me
wow true magic where two of you gather
in my name
say it
in Latin
with you come here
levitate yes obligatory levity check
s
it's like Dr Strange Magic
[Music]
money shot
knock it off we're not done yet
does that sound like a video game
character yeah I will take you both
oh no
sexy
that's somebody's King
bless the water
uh yeah get that righteous police
not expect that that is this movie yeah
that's the wild kill
in the name of the Holy Father
God
so it really got brought to life for
these people
I guess whoa
did they have like a camera flash charge
sound to that crossbeat
oh
dope
that cool okay 2000 supernatural horror
right there
Ghost Rider actually
got dragged to hell until they beat it
for now the devil's always out there
will they do they ever so different
there were two of them I guess it was
time for them to be vanquished
that's why
that's powerful
foreign
both priests died shortly after this
event
moments later due to heavily bodily
trauma internal bleeding and otherwise
the congregation has requested a full
report
can tell me again that evil only exists
in my imagination Cardinal Solomon has
taken a sabbatical in the Isle of Guam
and everyone who thinks like him as well
she even is good
this soil
the family has safely relocated back to
the U.S where the boy made a full
ricolani
and had no trauma whatsoever asmodeus
has been defeated but there are many
more to be found soon we will know all
of the other
199 sites on Earth the two weeks
I just need a horror franchise please oh
then a lifetimes work for one priest but
two priests oh my God they should do a
pre-cinematic universe an ensemble of
priests let's go to work
yeah yeah let's go to hell
it's right on dude
hell yeah
let's go
this movie is something man
wow 2016. I gotta guessing
the books are good
[Music]
ah
what a rousing true story Julius Avery
I've I've heard that name before but I
might be getting it confused
it is based on two of his books and they
were good
good books must be full of nothing but
horror cliches yeah
the pulp novelist father Gabriella
foreign
I mean if if this is anywhere near what
he's writing about I mean
that's pretty much what you got to look
forward to
this is like if the conjuring decided
that the family wasn't really that
important
I know all that stuff they set up with
the family to have a whole little
grievance Arc tale it's like we're
driving off yep we're leaving it's the
end of it it's done this movie can't be
three hours dissolution with us yep
see ya give every character beat to
Russell Crowe
set him up for sequels yeah
two priests can get it done
wow that was so cheesy
and then when it wasn't it was kind of
boring
yeah it had a a a salvaging amount of
cheese and uh some pretty you know
Punchy jump scare and Gorge like when it
descends into being the kind of movie
you expected to be like it's it's decent
at doing that
but Russell Crowe especially just ties
the entire thing together oh dude it was
made in conjunction with tsg
entertainment oh the best
all right all right the Pope's Exorcist
come on what this has a 47 Rotten
Tomatoes score 81 audience that's right
um which one is the correct score I
wanna see what this director did
Julius Avery it did Overlord yes damn I
should have found it out I thought yeah
his whole Direction just felt like an
action movie yeah yeah and and I mean
yeah overall obviously the salon movie
yeah yeah Samaritan so action horror
period Bradford no you know McGregor
movie okay yeah my okay yeah
um yeah I mean overload was great
um Overlord this felt like it felt like
an action movie director yeah
um but no I felt like it was a bit at
odds at this I'm like is this self-aware
or is it
completely done selfish
what are you trying to do and are you
succeeding or not yeah or are you
succeeding in spite of yourself that it
has like the rock and roll music it has
like the tag at the end of like is it
the books are good and then it's got
this like Cinematic Universe franchise
sequel set up at the end yeah they've
got their whole prodigium right there
they've got their whole base of
operation
um but no it was like nothing but Trope
Central yeah nothing but whereas you
take something like Overlord which
has a lot of familiarity with its setup
and its premise but it had a very unique
way of going about it that was actually
filled with tension and genuine
excitement or this was nothing but
it was like literally nothing but tropes
with a couple of moments that were like
oh cool I like the makeup is a fun
looking set yeah a lot of interesting
location there's an interesting
intention here with priest overcoming
his own traumas in order to defeat him
when they were doing the whole
Exposition dump about like what's
underneath his house Conquistador all
that stuff when they were doing all that
it just like they wouldn't just stop dog
finding the information and I was seeing
so I was checking out I was like I'm
starting to lose out of this because I'm
a little bored what do you mean
so poor just like just explaining so
[__] long it would have stopped like
being read a book yeah
um yes it was so boring there and uh
that's what I mean when it started like
get serious then he's doing his
confession and while I think Russell
Crowe really elevates this and like Alex
Esso is great as well
the other priest guy is good too yeah
um yeah it it just
I just didn't really I just found myself
I started off having fun with it and
then I found myself getting bored with
it
and then the finale started bringing me
back around a little bit more
um but now like I I just kept waiting
for something to give me some unique
something that was truly is something
that was unique but man it just it was
like a whole bunch of different movies
yeah um and every single Trope and you
could predict lines you know when you
could get to the point where you can
predict the lines you got a real problem
liner
um
yeah and they dropped the whole premise
of the family as well with the I
couldn't tell if if they never wrote
that stuff or if that stuff was removed
just so that this wouldn't be like so
long that it becomes actually tedious so
long what do you mean they just needed
to have like a little button of them
overcoming the grief
just like had five minutes on it here
just to [__] resolve have a little
resolution well yeah I guess throughout
the movie it's like you you meet them I
don't know you feel like again The
Conjuring is like a very solid
Touchstone for something like this or
the nun I guess is more apt because yeah
it's like you're like The Conjuring
means the net yeah totally and it's like
you're gonna meet your family who's
gonna be the heart of the movie and then
you're gonna meet the people who you
know you're gonna meet your Warrens or
whoever your uh figure of uh safety and
authority and your chance to stop this
and those are going to be kind of the
two centers of everything and I feel
like we ultimately got to know the other
priest a lot better than we got to know
anyone in the family because they're
once they set up that dad's dead and
there's the trauma and they have the
inheritance and the boy was in the car
like you you don't learn anything about
that they're also very cliche set of
characters they are yeah yeah and they
don't feel like anybody thought about
them aside from the actors like beyond
that point so it's like you have the
family you have the mom and daughter
only there
to spark set pieces and and it seemed
like the movie wasn't doing that at
first yeah it seemed like there was
going to be about the relationship
between Russell Crowe and her in some
way yeah it seemed like it was gonna but
it seemed like it wanted to do some kind
of elevated you know character based you
know like you know sad story about this
family you know grieving and overcoming
that and this is all kind of a metaphor
for that and it sets up like early on
you know you're joking about like oh
that's gonna be a theme you know like
love and it's like yeah the mother's
love thing like comes back but it's not
like a big you know tied around you know
element of the character's growth
through the story it's just like oh hey
we got an opening window just remind me
or his mom real quick yeah yeah so it's
like it's it feels like all that stuff
could have been happening off screen but
it doesn't feel like they really care to
do much of any of that which just makes
those scenes feel kind of odd because
again everybody's putting in so much you
know everyone's really showing up and uh
you know bringing the performances and
yet they feel like they're kind of left
to flail
yeah yeah
um music was fine it just in the the the
the
the look of the the movie just really
needed some type of mood it needed some
type of mood and atmosphere it was
lacking in that so much and
I I think that would have really helped
Propel that like as the the editing was
kind of like gnarly to me it just
wouldn't stop cutting around I thought
though the uniqueness came in the form
of who our main character is yeah of
this kind of badass
Exorcist Pope and priest uh who this
badass Exorcist who's got kind of a
plays by his own rules rugged
personality he's like that what you
think he's working with the rookie card
oh yeah yeah he's got friction from the
chief yeah it's a cop movie it is it's
essentially a cop who people with this
new Hot Shot transferred in from the
Metropolitan City he's traumatized by
his pass case and he [__] up his fast
case this is redemption yeah yeah and it
was some woman too it's like a film Noir
thing yeah it's very much it's very much
that and and and his character is the
main thing that is unique here because
it could have been just a very cliche
thing and even when I saw like a little
bit of the trailer I thought that's what
it was going to be from Russell Crowe uh
but I thought he brought a lot of life
to it and he is easily the best part of
this movie a thousand percent the best
part and he was very committed and he
never seemed like he was laughing at
what he was in surprisingly he actually
found like the exact right mood in Pitch
yeah for this to the point where I'm
like he's having fun same time he
doesn't seem like he is yeah it doesn't
it seems like he's just cash and check
he actually feels like he really brought
a character to life here I'll be so
fascinated to know like like did he was
he like the first person to sign on like
how did all these other people like
because this is a got a decent casting
of Franco Nero in here too like who who
signed on first to get the amount of
talent that they had on at their
disposal that does yeah it's like you
see the ultimate thing and you're like
really all these people came together
for this script this is the movie they
all like were like no we gotta yeah pack
this thing well even Alex Esso he was
using like some very phenomenal pieces
of I mean Her Like She's mainly in
horror yeah and and she's like she's
carried movies in the past yeah yeah but
they even like the TV show she's on now
you know like she's uh
by Manor she's in midnight mass and yeah
she's been in like a ton of movies as
well when you see her and you expect her
to have like a juicy character yeah
she's really giving it her all and she's
doing a great job with what she's given
um as expected from a solid performer
like her and that is
he and also doctor sleep no am I wrong
about that I would have to double check
it but I wouldn't be surprised and I'm
pretty sure she's a kind of thing she's
one of Flanagan's actors yeah
um the flanigang yeah yeah and uh
and yeah I I thought that oh yeah I I
there's no there's no way around it's
just another cliches all right well yeah
and I think it doesn't feel real it just
doesn't feel lived in it like everything
felt like a set and the the worst part
is
ever
it kind of just runs through the Gambit
of cliches too without ever trying to
strike some type of tension through it
it's like the biggest the biggest
example is the the first time the cross
is going upside down and then it pans
down to Alex Esso it's just like just
throw it in there uh yeah let's do it
let's just move it in there and then
yeah you're right like some of the stump
works really well done so the makeup
looks really good all the technical like
the the sets are good the costuming is
good the actors and the effects and the
CG and the yeah that's definitely it
always felt like I was looking at a set
but I think the problem is uh something
about the way it is captured and edited
and perhaps directed doesn't bolster all
those things together into a synthesized
hole it just feels like you got a bunch
of excellent resources yeah that I
wasn't ever able to fully lose myself
into like it's luckily fun and it's like
over it's part of the thing about
Overlord is
tropes though that movie has it leans it
Embraces its b-moviness it's it's
schlockness and I feel like this is
maybe torn between
I don't know in the age of The Conjuring
I feel like we shouldn't be teetering on
this Edge but like I see the the imagery
in the marketing and stuff and I think
like okay this is going to be like a
more restrained Russell Crowe is going
to be a bit more dramatic and a bit more
elevated to use the term everyone hates
um and then you get inside and you're
like oh no this is much more of a fun
house and I feel like they should have
then perhaps embraced that further
because I could feel moments where it's
like no we want to make this like a
serious drama film except we're not
going to do any of that kind of pacing
or some work and we're not going to
flesh much of anything out and so yeah
it kind of flails in the middle between
being something that is a bit more Hefty
and dramatic and based on a true story
versus something that is just wild and
giving you the indulge it's like this
does have like the blasphemy that you
want I think out of any Exorcist movie
and I think oftentimes with a people dog
the based on a true story you look at
something like The Conjuring but I think
that's kind of what people want is like
you want the movie to go nuts you know
you want the movie to convince to make
you wonder if it's real and then go
crazy with it and this movie never
really gives you the time to be like is
it really could it really just be the
psychology thing could it could it just
be all in these people's heads you know
before you get to the point where like
things are flying around and like the
second they move into the house you're
like nope something completely
Supernatural is happening I know it man
you know it's a great setup like the
setup with the with the with the priest
character
um with Russell crows Gabriel that was a
great setup yeah uh but yeah I feel like
the whole movie is kind of a metaphor
for like the first time you see the
diocese the the house they're moving
into it's like you get this huge place
with like a freaking catacombs and like
you cut down there at one point and I'm
like
this is part of the house right like it
it breezes so quickly through that
there's no like real moment to like walk
in take in the space set everything up
establish that atmosphere and I feel
like that you know introduction to the
setting of the movie to the to this
house is also kind of a good uh analogy
for the rest of the movie it's like you
once you walk in you're just kind of
going and you're never really taking it
a moment to drink anything in or or sit
with an idea or you know feel the impact
of what these guys are going through and
I feel like you know especially a lot of
people have religious backgrounds that
this stuff you don't have to go as crazy
or you can you know entertain the you
know intellectual sides at least a
little bit because a lot of people
struggle with those aspects of faith and
Superstition and whatnot it's like I
don't think you need to make this like a
full-on cinema film but uh I feel like
some of those instincts could have
helped or or just going yeah full full
schlock or something like that yeah and
that's what I meant when I first said at
the top that it said a Crossroads with
itself sure yeah because I I I've lost
sight of whether or not this is actually
self-aware because at first I thought it
was like a rock and roll playlist
and they do that Motif twice and then
they don't really come back to it
um but then it but but then but then it
seems like no you they want to take this
serious yeah
and it's like they would want you to
when it gets to that point I started
really checking out and I just found
myself
um less interested as it went with a
couple of visual flourishes once in a
while like whatever it reminded me it
was an R-rated movie I might be a little
bit more uh pulled in for that Split
Second yeah because there's a lot of
PG-13 movies like this yes and this just
feels like
this is
the R-rated veil of it you know yeah
totally where it's you can also see the
PG-13 version because the r-ratedness of
it
doesn't really pack a punch of until
there's a couple of Gore moments the r
ratedness of it just kind of feels
yeah it feels a little cheap uh with its
dialogue of its of of the way they go
with the f word the vulgarity of it
sometimes it doesn't actually register
to me as
truly
demonic no yeah I wouldn't say it feels
truly demonic or
or Sinister it it just reads like a
screenplay trying hard it's like what a
teenager would try and come up with for
demon diet yeah
yeah and so due to that fact yeah I
would not
I I'm not high on this movie it's one of
those movies I saw ESO up here I thought
like oh maybe you know this is gonna be
yeah this might be better than expected
or something like that or or even more
than I expected in some way but uh yeah
this is one of those ones where like the
initial ride is fun but I don't and then
just discovering what weird wavelength
this movie is on is fun but I wouldn't
be compelled to be like add this to your
so bad it's good list or add this to
your underrated gems list or gotta watch
this again you know it's like once
you've seen it you get it there's some
there's some neat like for for
particularly demonic horror like this I
think there are some good set pieces and
stuff there are some good images in
terms of just like some of the bloody
icky gags but uh but Mr benefit of the
doubt I would say that there is nothing
here that is actually original no no
there's not like almost anything except
for maybe the entirely that analogy of
going okay buddy cop but they're priests
and it's exorcism other than that I know
they should just lean they should they
should have just embraced that that's
what they were doing and instead of
trying to like sneak it in yeah no
totally just again yeah do that thing
where it's like we can tell that you're
not taking it too seriously behind the
camera but you're playing it straight
like lean into the lead into this alt
genre that you want to be yeah you know
and that will make us more excited for
these super priest man or whatever the
[__] you're doing or or make it Super
Freeze cop Dynamic yeah really really
commit to it so that we want to see more
of that happen in these potential
sequels yeah yeah I think that would
have been way more fun if they're like
would would an exorcism case is too yeah
the off the books Exorcist yeah yeah the
priest who doesn't play by the rules or
get along with anyone else but he's kept
it long because at the end of the day he
gets the job done yeah yeah no one knows
demons like Father Gabriella yeah yeah
totally I I think they there was a a
genuinely fun movie that could have been
made from this yeah and they didn't and
a movie that made you care about
anything because even by the time he
gets possessed and then it's going
through it's right it's just literally
just it's just checklist movie yeah it's
like you can see where all the beats are
going except for the one like I thought
the one guy would get possessed they did
that with his sister instead but like
yeah like you you need a heart I feel
like the priests are good and and
watching them deal with their
vulnerabilities they don't get to know
the family but they need the family
heart they needed to get to know the
sister and the and the and the mom yeah
like that's where your core of this is
not really what is your relationship
there's two like stoic priests in
reasonably Charming priests getting to
know each other it's
and it seems like you know they get in
there and they're mostly only focused on
the like the movie's intentions and
attention is only focused on this demon
not about like the well-being of this
family no their experiences like even
the kid that much
they look at the end they're like and
they went home and the kid was fired and
I'm like what is the aftermath it
doesn't even seem interested in checking
in on this kid yeah like go see them at
least or give us some kind of wrap up or
yeah like early on they should be like
getting to know the family so that they
can understand the traumas intimately as
well as their relationship so they can
call upon specifics to use to appeal to
the boys Humanity like yeah it it really
I think misses out especially on having
tone aside there's no emotional course
so you basically have the appeal of
Russell Crowe to hold everything
together yeah yeah um but it's it's
surface visuals with nothing really
underneath it whether that be something
that is genuine like endearingly fun or
genuinely scary like there was never
really a there would be like a moment of
like oh
but but there was never an actual scene
that was scary it was never an actual
scene that was tense never you never
feel like you're in the room two hour
movie is there one scene where I'm like
oh that is an actual scary scene yeah
like oh that's kind of a it's kind of
creepy with The Nightmare on Elm Street
pulling him into the bed kind of vibe
all right but even that could feel more
impactful and more like a nightmare
rather than like one of many random
things happening at this moment no it's
the whole thing is just a bunch of
Randomness and like throwing people into
it's more into [__] but without but even
the way it's captured is not done with
any sense of like self I'm talking about
the way they use the camera work with
this is not done with any type of
self-awareness like even if it is
derivative you you could kind of use a
bit of a Phil Lord and Chris Miller
touch or an Edgar Wright touch to to
have some of that self-awareness of what
you're doing here so you can have an
energy and a like I would like last
night in SoHo there's a lot of
derivativeness in that you know
um but there is such but there's
uniqueness too as well well yeah I have
to write it's actually the perfect
example I think for this but if someone
who like knows a genre yeah really leans
into the genre tropes but then also does
a lot of unique things and that's what
this needed was was to have that sense
of uh of awareness who did James want
like actually we would say Conjuring
this whole time but like malignant kind
of does that you know yeah totally and
this misses that Mark too because this
feel like malignant is half of an action
movie crashed into a horror movie and
this felt like they got a horror movie
pack of Aesthetics and just directed it
like a 90-minute action movie yeah like
a 90 minute action comedy
yeah all right
can you close this out yeah guys
I didn't even want to like talk about
sports
when it was all said and done I was like
I wanna I wanna turn off the camera on
board not not as great as the sum of its
parts unfortunately but guys who's your
favorite Exorcist have you read any of
these books and are they good let us
know and uh Hey subscribe to the channel
hit that notification Bell so you can
learn when another reactions coming your
way thank you for joining us and uh
peace be with you
via condios
[Music]